ce soir jamais vous parlez d'une amitié
qui m'est très cher alors c'est une
amitié un peu particulière parce que mon
ami est une petite fille et malgré son
jeune âge j'apprends beaucoup avec elle
j'aimerais vous parler un peu d'elle
parce qu'elle est vraiment formidable
déjà c'est une petite fille qui déborde
d'énergie
elle a vraiment la joie de vivre elle
est toujours enthousiaste quand tu lui
propose quelque chose elle est toujours
partante et c'est un vrai bonheur
elle est aussi drôle ça avait petit
clown quand je suis avec elle mais je me
masse et un petit gag elle a toujours
des petites blagues à raconter c'est
super elle est aussi super curieuse tout
ce qui est inconnu elle veut découvrir
c'est une aventurière est elle toujours
essayer de nouvelles choses et ça aussi
je trouve ça génial
et puis elle a quelque chose qui me
fascine elle a un rêve
et ce rêve est la confiance en ce rêve
et quand tu lui dis plus tard qu'est ce
que tu feras elle te parle de son rêvé
elle a une assurance une force et moi ça
m'épate
parce que à cet âge là c'est c'est
impressionnant et malheureusement cette
petite on s'est un peu perdu de vue et
elle me manque beaucoup mais on vous
racontant l'histoire de son rêve ça me
rappelle que moi aussi j'avais un rêve à
son âge alors moi j'ai grandi à guarin
et est assez rapidement vais vraiment
peut-être vers trois quatre ans j'ai
naturellement été attiré par tout ce qui
était dessins coloriages peinture alors
que mes parents n'étaient pas du tout
artiste et moi on me dit quand j'étais
petite à le métier dans un coin sur un
pee wee avec des feuilles des clients et
pendant des heures je pouvais des signes
et coloris c'était moi et pas d'un mois
et puis à 6 ans j'ai fait une rencontre
qui a fait naître un rêve alors cette
personne est un artiste à ces
incontournables en polynésie s'agit de
bobby hull comme est en fait en
rencontrant bobby j'ai réalisé que ben
ma passion et bah ça pouvait
un métier et donc à l'âge de 6 ans j'ai
décidé comme moi quand je serai grande
je serai artistes comme bobby alors
c'est mignon les enfants avec des rêves
donc en gros 10 ans me disait alors toi
quand tu feras grande qu'est ce que tu
feras moi je serai artistes c'est bien
il sait quoi artistes belges et frais
des tableaux et ça fait joli mimizan
aussi mignon c'est bien et puis voilà
les années ont passé et je me suis
accroché à mon rêve et puis au lycée ben
alla proche du bac bat toujours la même
question
alors qu'est ce que tu vas faire plus
tard et leur moi ma artistes et le
soutien que j'avais eue pendant tant
d'années avait tout d'un faux disparu
c'est à dire que là on me disait mr ton
ma chérie artiste c'est pas un vrai
métier il faut que tu réfléchisses à un
vrai métier à tisser quelque chose que
tu fais un côté c'est une passion c'est
en robbie mais tu fais ça le week-end
mais tu tu veux c'est pas un métier
et là je sais pas quel âge avait je
devais avoir peut-être quinze ans de 16
ans et ça a été dur ça a vraiment été
dur parce que quelque part il fallait
que je renonce à ce rêve parce que
j'étais jeune parce que j'étais
influençable parce que j'avais pas
confiance en moi j'ai renoncé à ses
rêves et quelque part je me suis coupé
les aide parce que renoncer à un rêve
eh ben c'est venons c'est à beaucoup de
choses
et donc voilà je suis rentré dans le
moule
je me suis plié à ce que mon entourage
et la société attendait de moi donc
après le bac bac est ce qu'on fait on
fait des études bon bain ou qui ont fait
des études alors ben j'ai fait des
études et qu'est-ce que j'ai choisi
comme étude des études passe partout qui
me permettrait d'avoir le plus de
possibilités sur le marché du travail
donc des études qu'il m'intéressait
absolument pas mais au moins j'étais sûr
d'avoir un travail à la fin donc voilà
je suis des études et puis
une fois mon diplôme en poche bas qu'est
ce qu'on fait la recherche d'un travail
bon bah qu'est ce que je vais faire
aller je m'inscris un concours
d'enseignement parce que ben enseignants
c'est un bon métier c'est ce qu'on
attend de moi c'est un bon salaire c'est
la sécurité c'est une bonne retraite
donc voilà j'ai commencé à cocher des
cases donc voilà bagcheck études tchèque
concours tchèque carrière tchèque qu'est
ce qu'on fait après dance est un emprunt
bancaire ont fait un emprunt pour
construire une maison à les empreintes
chèques maisons tchèque et j'étais
malheureuse j'étais tellement
malheureuse et le pire dans tout ça
c'est que je m'en voulais c'est à dire
que je me disais mais c'est quoi ton
problème quoi enfin je veux dire tu es
vraiment une enfant gâtée oui c'est tout
bon là a tout pour être heureuse était
là je suis pas heureuse et il s'est
passé quelque chose
mon corps a commencé à m'envoyer des
messages alors le kof c'est quelque
chose de très intelligent et quand les
choses ne vont pas bien
il nous le fait sentir mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait nous avait on écoute pas donc
moi mon corps va m'envoyer des messages
le coût du parent c'est ça c'est ça
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai 25 ans premiers
boutons
j'avais pas eu un bouton de ma vie et
tout d'un coup juste il commence à des
boutons du stress en permanence des
insomnies la boule au ventre
à chaque rentrée les crises de pleurs et
je mets côté toujours pas et à un moment
là mon corps il m'a envoyé un message
tellement fort qu'il a bien fallu que je
les écoute j'ai fait une grosse
dépression mais vraiment une grosse
dépression et là il ya eu un déclic je
me suis dit non mais attends si tu
continues à bat écouter peut-être que le
produit un message va te cloué et tu
pourras pas te relever est alors à ce
moment-là vous souvenez de mon ami la
petite fille
ben je les retrouver en fait à ce moment
là et ça m'a fait un bien fou parce que
en fait vous avez peut-être pas me
croire mais elle n'avait pas changé
c'était la même elle avait toutes les
qualités que j'avais toujours adoré chez
elle et je me
souviens d'une conversation avec elle et
ont rattrapé le temps et elle me dit
mais je comprends pas pourquoi t'es pas
heureuse je dis pas voilà j'aime pas mon
métier puis voilà
elle me dit mémé toi ce que tu aimes
c'est la peinture je dis bah oui dit
mais pourquoi tu fais pas de la peinture
c'est ça qui te rend heureuse c'est
simple ben oui c'est simple en fait on
devrait écouter les enfants beaucoup
plus en france beaucoup plus souvent un
ils sont ils sont vraiment très lucide
et donc voilà j'ai décidé de changer de
vie alors je ne vais pas vous cacher que
ça n'a pas été facile
ça a été difficile mais ça a été
libérateur alors quelles ont été les
difficultés alors la première difficulté
ça a été mon entourage ce fameux
entourage qui ne m'avaient pas soutenu
dix ans auparavant est de me soutenir
encore au moins dix ans plus tard c'est
à dire que on a cherché dix mille
excuses pour ne pas que je quitte mon
métier mais enfin machine et c'est la
crise de la trentaine ça va passer
t'inquiète pas c'est bon enfin mais ça
va pas la tête tu vas quitter profs mais
tu t'en pente pas travailler dur tu
gagne bien sa vie et ta retraite mais ça
va pas mais non non non c'est pas
possible
pour faire quoi assiste mitis à 10 tu
fais le week end en vacances
donc voilà il a fallu une fois de plus
enfin non pas une fois de plus puisque
dix ans auparavant je m'étais pas imposé
mais là je me suis imposé et j'ai dit
non là je m'écoute je ne vous écoute pas
et je vais vivre ce rêve
la deuxième difficulté qui a été
beaucoup plus difficile ça a été
moi-même en fait parce que j'avais envie
de cette nouvelle vie mais en même temps
j'étais terrorisée j'avais peur peur de
l'échec
peur de ne pas y arriver peur de ne pas
gagner d'argent de ne pas pouvoir payer
mes pleines ne pas pouvoir marcher
armand j'ai peur de ne pas en être
capable
et je me dévaloriser beaucoup parce que
on fait beaucoup ça on n'a pas confiance
en soi on pense qu'on n'est pas capable
qu'on n'a pas les ressources qu'il faut
et donc ça a vraiment été une lutte et
heureusement j'ai gagné cette lutte
contre moi même et j'ai réussi à sauter
le pas alors ça a été libérateur mais
vraiment y'a pas nous enfin j'ai envie
de dire waouh
tout simplement parce que ma vie a
changé radicalement
c'est comme si en fait à l'âge de 15 ans
quand j'avais me lancer à mon rêve je
m'étais mise dans une prison une
plaisante doré mais une prison et là
tout d'un coup il y avait plus de
prisons plus de chaînes plus de bars ou
plus de filets j'étais libre est en fait
cette liberté elle est aimée sans limite
et là j'ai découvert une nouvelle vie
alors qu'est ce qui a changé
tout a changé déjà tous mes petits
problèmes de santé ont disparu voyager
plus de boutons et j'ai compris ce que
c'était un esprit sain dans un corps
sain parce que quand on est bien dans sa
tête et ben ya tout qui suit donc je me
sentais bien dans mon corps bien dans ma
tête forte en bonne santé et prête à
affronter cette nouvelle vie il ya aussi
beaucoup de choses qui ont changé dans
ma vie dans mon entourage
parce que vous pensez bien qu'avant
j'étais malheureuse j'étais stressé et
quand je rentrais à la maison et ben
j'étais de mauvaise humeur donc qui s'en
prenait plein la figure
mon mari mes amis ma famille est là tout
d'un coup j'étais bien et une harmonie
en fête s'est installée et tout le monde
me disait ma femme qu'est ce que tu as
fait mais c'est incroyablement disait
tu es solaire des positive et donc ça a
rejailli en fait sur tout le monde et il
ya aussi quelque chose que j'ai
découvert et ça franchement c'est c'est
vraiment un trésor je me suis découvert
moi et j'ai découvert en fait le
potentiel que j'avais et on n'imagine
pas à quel point on a un potentiel
illimité
je me suis découverte des ressources des
capacités des idées dès que j'aurais
jamais imaginé trois ans auparavant et
de pouvoir voilà les les réaliser les
faire j'en ai genre ressentait une
grande fierté et une grande confiance
est donc vraiment cette nouvelle vie ça
a été une renaissance en fait fait une
nouvelle des vérités qui est née une des
vérités que je ne soupçonnais même pas
et franchement voilà je ne regrette rien
et en fait j'ai une petite confidence à
vous faire la petite fille ma petite
copine l'a en fait
bah c'était moi et tout le long elle
était là mais je ne l'écoutait pas et
aujourd'hui j'essaye de lui laisser la
place qu'elle mérite
j'essaye de l'écouter le plus possible
j'essaye d'être attentive à ses besoins
parce que elle elle sait ce qu'il ya de
mieux pour moi
alors faites vous confiance
écoutez votre voix intérieure
laissez votre petit enfant intérieur
s'exprimer pourquoi pour vous épanouir
pour vous réaliser et être heureux tout
simplement pas au loup droit
[Applaudissements]